c'est une petite fille qui arrive en
retard à l'école arrive en retard à
l'école elle a un grand pansement autour
du front et la maîtresse se dit mais
pourquoi tu es en retard il dit parce
que je me suis fait piquer par une guêpe
elle dit mais une guêpe ça nécessite pas
un grand bandage et d'ici parce que mon
papa il a essayé de la tuer avec la
pelle
c'est un mec qui passe devant le juge
lui dit écoutez monsieur quels sont les
faits qui vous sont reprochés et dit
Monsieur j'ai fait mes courses de Noël
un peu trop tôt et des bas c'est pas
vrai par la loi ça mais qu'est-ce que
vous avez payé est-ce que vous appelez
un peu trop tôt dis bah le magasin il
était fermé
[Applaudissements]
visite à l'hôpital et il vient le voir
il dit qu'on a grandi ensemble on est
des potes et d'un coup le mec qui sert
son pote japonais le serpent
et le japonais fait
donc lui il est un peu dégoûté bon il
l'appelle il y a la mer du du japonais
sa petite amie qui vient et d'écouter
voilà votre votre fils et votre mari il
est mort mais il a une dernière volonté
mais je comprends pas le japonais moi il
dit c'est quoi la dernière volonté il a
dit
ça veut dire lâche-moi je suis en train
de tout faire
c'est l'histoire d'un couple ça fait 45
ans qui sont mariés ils veulent fêter
leur 45e année de mariage il invite au
restaurant il lui dit écoute ma chérie
maintenant ça fait 45 ans dis-moi les
vérités est-ce que tu m'as déjà trompé
sa femme elle le regarde et écoute je te
rappelle la maison qu'on a acheté et
dis-lui fallait un crédit oui bon le
crédit il a été refusé et il se mène
après il a été accepté je me suis chelou
le banquier est devenu gentil elle dit
bah voilà j'ai couché avec le banquier
le gars il la regarde c'était la seule
fois il dit non
tu t'es fait virer de ton travail et dis
oui et la semaine d'après il t'a
rembauché ton patron et dit oui bah
parce que j'ai vu le patron puis bon il
dit bon c'est pas grave tu as couché
pour la bonne cause il dit c'est tout il
dit non trapège
pendant les élections il fallait sensé
qu'on le voit
c'est Louis Boyard
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est Louis brouillard comme il
était député maintenant il s'est raconté
un peu dans les paris un jour il se dit
bon je vais aller voir les hôpitaux
psychiatriques comment ça se passe
il rentre dans un hôpital psychiatrique
le docteur et le reconnu dit bonjour
monsieur Boyard vous êtes venu on sait
très bien pourquoi vous êtes venu faire
de la pub allez venez et voyez-vous
comment vous savez quand un fou il est
plus fou elle dit bah c'est simple on
fait des tests là par exemple regarder
on va faire un test on va remplir une
baignoire plein d'eau et à chaque fois
on va leur proposer trois trucs soit une
cuillère pour vider la pour vider la
baignoire on leur proposer soit une
cuillère soit une fourchette soit un
seau d'eau et Louis Boyard c'est normal
celui qui est guéri normalement il prend
le seau d'eau il dit non celui qui est
guéri retire le bouchon
[Applaudissements]
j'ai un problème je me suis réveillé le
matin il y a 50 poules qui sont morts
comment je peux faire et du coup ce que
tu fais va voir tes poules ce soir
raconte-leur une histoire comme ça ils
vont dormir et personne va mourir il est
d'accord il va le raconter l'histoire il
était une fois un prince une princesse
maman il se réveille le matin sans poule
qui meurent
regardez j'ai fait ça dis-moi c'est ce
que c'est chantez-lui du Jean-Jacques
Goldman chanter le Jean-Jacques Goldman
le soir ça va leur faire du bien ils
vont dormir l'autre il arrive elle a
fait un bébé tout
il part en concert de Jean-Jacques
Goldman il se réveille le matin 200
poules qui meurent
il va voir
solutions mais ça marche pas est-ce que
vous avez d'autres solutions le tu l'as
dit moi des solutions j'en ai mais
est-ce que toi tu as assez de poule
et ça se passe dans un village ouais tu
es une vieille dame très âgée c'est la
doyenne du village qui vit avec son
petit-fils qui est muet
mais un jour elle tombe malade là les
gens du village ils viennent la voir
sauf que c'est le muet qui ouvre la
porte et elle lui a dit quand il y a
quelqu'un tu me dis qui c'est donc ça
attaque à la porte il va il ouvre la
porte c'est le mécanicien qui arrive
il va la voir
comment ça va ça fait longtemps
ça me fait de la peine de vous voir
malade il s'en va une demi-heure après
il y a le plombier qui arrive et toque
il va avoir le premier il arrive pas on
va voir
c'est le premier dialogue c'est le
rentrer le plombier il arrive
une heure après il y a le maire du
village qui arrive et toque il ouvre le
mieux il voit que c'est le maire la
grand-mère c'est qui
ça se passe dans un mariage il y a la
mariée qui arrive et mec il se retourne
il prend la commande
ma fille là déjà pardon je savais pas
que vous étiez son père je suis pas son
père je suis sa mère
c'est un mec qui rentre bourré
complètement bourré il pose la bouteille
de vodka il se glisse à côté de sa femme
et une demi-heure après écris je t'aime
c'est toi qui parle ou c'est la
bouteille de vodka qui parle et c'est
moi qui parle à la bouteille de vodka
c'est un mec il meurt il arrive au
paradis et un moment où il arrive au
Paradis on lui fait un peu visiter le
paradis tu vois il visite le paradis
d'un coup
ça bière il ouvre la porte et lui dit
bah là par exemple c'est la chambre des
horloges c'est quoi les horloges chaque
être humain il a son horloge et dès
qu'il dit une bêtise l'aiguille elle
bouge un peu et elle continue à bouger à
chaque fois que tu dis une connerie
[ __ ] c'est chaud il dit elle est où
l'horloge de Mélenchon et du bas
celle-là je m'en sers en ventilateur
c'est Louis Boyard
je connais pas il est dans un avion et
d'un coup l'avion pilote il dit
attention va se cracher oui c'est chelou
prenez vos parachutes et sauter et lui
bon comme tu le connais il saute il
oublie son parachute et il saute
et là d'un coup il voit apparaître
devant lui Emmanuel Macron
Emmanuel Macron le Président il dit
écoute crie vive Macron je te sauve la
vie
continue
il descend il descend et du bon d'accord
vivement trop vive Macron et là il y a
Mélenchon qui arrive il le réveille et
dit non seulement tu dors pendant les
réunions et en plus j'écris des
conneries
c'est deux mecs qui font un accident de
voiture parce qu'il y en a un qui brûle
le feu et l'autre il brûle le feu aussi
il faut un accident de voiture il meurt
tous les deux ils arrivent en enfer
parce qu'ils ont brûlé le feu quand ils
arrivent à l'enfer ils disent ouais ben
écoutez on aimerait bien d'abord
prévenir nos familles on prévient nos
familles ils écoutaient ici on a on
enfer on a un téléphone dis monsieur
vous habitez où dis-moi j'habite à
Neuilly alors rappelez vos familles de
Neuilly par contre la minute elle est à
400 €. et c'est quelqu'un de votre
famille qui va payer la minute il dit
c'est pas grave d'après la loi j'ai fait
un accident je suis mort vas-y laisse
tomber préviens tout le monde et ta
deuxième mec il arrive il dit bah moi
aussi je peux appeler dit ouais vous
habitez où dis-moi j'habite à
Aubervilliers dans le 93 combien je vous
dois il dit non de l'enfer à l'enfer
c'est gratuit
un mec qui rentre dans un bar il se pose
à côté du barman et dites-moi un jus
d'orange s'il te plaît
une personne qui va sortir des toilettes
et qui va dire il y a plus de papier
toilette 10 minutes après mais qui sort
excusez-moi il y a plus de papier
toilette
dans 20 minutes et un mec grand costaud
il va rentrer il va te dire mais moi un
café sans sucre et un café avec sucre 20
minutes après un mec excusez-moi café
sans sucre un café avec sucre et là pour
toute cette celle-là il y a un mec est
en face sur le comptoir il a vu toute
cette scène il vient de voir une
excusez-moi monsieur depuis tout à
l'heure je vous regarde vous avez deviné
tout ce qui s'est passé il dit c'est
normal je suis devant
comment vous faites vous voulez
apprendre à être devant aussi dit
d'accord alors venez avec moi il emmène
chez lui il dit rentrer mais bon
mettez-vous à quatre pattes
vous allez me faire un truc chelou et
ben voilà ça commence vous commencez
Emmanuel Macron il en visite en
Australie
pour un peu d’être ordre
monsieur Macron va faire un peu la
visite de Sydney on va se balader en
Australie et là ils sont en voiture et
un mouton qui passe et Emmanuel Macron
ça c'est un mouton
qu'est-ce qu'ils sont gros qu'est-ce
qu'ils sont balaise c'est pas mouton ça
il marche et tout et d'un coup il lui
dit et ça c'est quoi il dit ça ça c'est
un lapin
les lapins en France ils sont balaise
grand super et là d'un coup il y a un
kangourou qui passe non ça c'était quoi
petit dessin c'est une sauterelle
Cyril Hanouna et bouder
ils ont passé le BEP ensemble et le jour
des résultats bah Cyril il peut pas
venir il me dit bouder s'il te plaît je
peux pas venir je dois passer la journée
avec mes parents et
appelle-moi pour me dire les résultats
mais on va mettre une stratégie en place
comme je vais être haut-parleur si j'ai
raté un examen tu me dis à l'eau Cyril
comment tu vas si j'ai raté deux examens
tu me dis allô Cyril comment tu vas
comment il va ton père
on arrive le lundi je regarde les
résultats j'appelle Cyril il y a le
Cyril comment tu vas toi ton père ta
mère
[Applaudissements]
à Casablanca il y a un taxi là à l'arrêt
et là tout de suite il y a une dame qui
rentre elle est complètement nue elle
rentre elle s'installe derrière elle est
complètement à poils comme un fou il
regarde dans le rétroviseur et la dame
elle dit mais écoutez monsieur
j'ai jamais vu une femme toute nue et
qui mange me demande juste il est où
l'argent pour que tu payes la course
[Applaudissements]